from start to finish what is your
process for writing a movie
from star i mean the the start if we're
really going to like the start start
i'm watching a movie that i love like i
like my
my aforementioned matrix revisit
revisiting where i was like
ideas were just fireworks in my brain
after that i have to you know all these
ideas are populating up there
um from there you know you have now this
energy that's like just
glowing inside of you to create and
that's where i start being like okay
what what can i you know i'm seeing
elements of this that really inspired me
what elements of this can i take to
create something that's my own
and and then that's where i'll start
toying around with
a scene it usually just starts with one
scene where i'll see that so crystal
clear
it's one of my favorite moments of the
creation process
um and then and then to write that scene
i don't always start a script from the
very beginning i'll sometimes start what
i see the clearest
so i'll start with that and then
you know once you you've looked at that
scene and you kind of alright is the
rest of the story starting to fall into
place do i see what's going to be
happening now in this story
if the answer is yes keep going so then
then i might start from the very
beginning okay let's get work our way up
to this scene and try and get there
um so i'll you know do the draft usually
the first draft is
i don't want to call it a mess because i
don't think it's a mess but it's it's
not
it's not textbook screenwriting you know
it's not perfect the actions aren't
purely actions the actions are a little
bit descriptive up there like i'm like
living in that flowery
description on my screen my first draft
of my screenplay um and
i just love it uh i think mark duplass
referred to
the first draft like that as like the
vomit draft you're just getting the idea
out
um and that's the perfect uh analogy for
it you're just
get this idea out i don't know it's a
gross analogy but you know you get it
um so anyways you know you do that draft
and then that's where
all right are we gonna do this are we
gonna find the elbow grease to like lift
this up and like tighten the script and
you know usually around this point
aaron has already been aware of like my
passion for this script like
is this something you're interested in
too because i mean hey he's gonna be the
one directing
so is he to be attached as the director
and we'll kind of come together and like
start talking about the project together
he'll usually at this point take it and
uh if he if he hasn't already sometimes
we're both in the same
stage together but uh he'll he'll then
take it
and start really like polishing it up
and he does such a phenomenal job of
of absolutely tightening a script
anything that's extra superfluous that
i've been like putting in there because
hey
pizzazz and it needs to be in there
right it doesn't need to be in there he
takes it out
he can see as the director exactly what
it's going to be and so he takes it out
and he'll
he'll really tighten it and it becomes
this beautiful well-oiled machine and
i'm so grateful because once he's had
his hands on it
i mean if he he'll kick it back to me
i'll read things and sometimes i'll
be like oh no you didn't see what needed
to be here in this scene did you not see
the emotional travesty that needed oh no
this has to come back
you know something that's when we kick
it back and forth and i mean that's the
fun
nerve-wracking probably in aaron's
opinion nerve-wracking
portion of the the uh collaborative
strip writing process between us
um because i'm a very passionate writer
if you can't tell
um but we're always like on the same
team we're always
on the same team rowing in the same
direction to finish this script and
make it the best possible project and we
know that we both know that we both know
that
each of us wants the best finished
product so
we just keep kicking it back and forth a
few times once it's really polished and
ready to go
then we send it out to family and
friends and start getting getting the
feedback see what people think and
they give great notes we have fantastic
friends who read everything
and they give fantastic notes and we
listen we really do it's not like we're
like
forget it they don't see it no we
totally listen and we're like oh i love
what they're that nugget of what they're
trying to tell us here let's try and
incorporate that and fix that here
and really simultaneously i'll have
already been working on the brand deck
because for me i love i live in visuals
so i'm creating this brand deck that has
i'm starting to like create the tone and
the color palette and maybe a little bit
of
styling and casting and so i'm really
like starting to draw that up too
what kind of male and female characters
do you want to write
like who are these people right and why
do you want to write them
i probably if i were to like
try and have a macro awareness for my
own style
i'm probably always writing characters
like
neo and wonder woman you know like
that's where i'm living i love love love
me
a good underdog someone who's who
just has good or at least they believe
they have good intentions and they're
just trying to make it
you know come hell or high water i mean
that is my jam
those are like all my favorite movies
have to do with some sort of like
someone coming up by their own
by their own way like they're going to
figure out their own way they're going
to find their strength they're going to
find their voice they're going to
figure out their confidence or they're
going to have one of those big moments
where
you know they're on stage and they
perfectly perform like i'm very much
that type of creator so i probably am
always going to be writing
characters of that nature and i love
that i think they're really inspiring
and fun and
they're characters that i like to see so
not let's say
black salon to
to dark to um machiavellian
i'm not sure if i'm saying the word
right but but something where there's
like a little more of um
the grit yeah and more of a more of a
because
those are good movies too but it seems
like you're more drawn to
the hero that's the underdog the sort of
needs to come up and prove
well see that might be where my
collaboration with aaron
really comes in clutch because he i
think
he does live a little bit more in that
black swan
character sort of creation um or at
least i see that he's able to do it he
can find
sort of those depths and those those
human
darknesses to to pull from it and like
put it in the character
and he does it very well like for me i'm
a little bit more of like
like i said i'm a little bit more in
that neo wonder woman element
but once he takes it and kind of infuses
something a little bit darker should the
story call for it
i mean that's very exciting can you
imagine you know uh the natalie portman
character mixed with a sort of wonder
woman
character i mean that's the character
i'm interested in checking out so if he
were to incorporate that into a script
that i kind of started drafting
i mean chef's kiss let's check it out i
want to see what's going on there
okay yeah how much time do you spend on
an idea before you start writing
like no time at all no i um
[Music]
it's alm it's almost like you know you
have like antsy fingers like i want
i don't want to forget this i don't want
to forget any of these details so a lot
of times
most of my ideas come to me later in the
evening and so uh my phone is my best
friend i'll have it
and i have an open email i send all my
email all my ideas to myself
and they're all just very stream of
consciousness like and don't forget to
do it like this and remember this type
of scare is better and
you know this all all these types of
things um
so yeah i'm like biting at the bit to
start putting things down
and and kind of see which one is going
to grow you know
you come up with a lot of ideas over the
course of you know if you're creating
you come up with them all the time
not every idea is going to make it to
the morning
you might wake up the next morning and
be like delete
that or i mean they go in like an idea
file you never know when it might come
back
um but by the way that's good yeah it's
good it's nice because then
you have fresh eyes in the morning and
you kind of read the ideas and you're
like
oh hmm there's something there um
so yeah i really spend like hardly any
time just keeping the idea
up there because i'm ready like once i
see it it's like all right let's put
this down even though it's not going to
be in the most beautiful format that i'm
writing
i'm still just putting it down in some
capacity kind of like a rough outline
and then maybe the next day it's like
all right i've got some time here with
my morning coffee let's
kind of just put a scene out and let's
see how the scene starts to look and
maybe this scene can become a short film
or maybe this is going to be like a
nugget for a larger story and that's
gonna
you know too soon to tell at that point
did you do any journal writing
when you were younger i did um my issue
was i
i really never liked like hand writing
things
i guess i was like a lazy handwriter no
i don't know
um i lost interest in the diaries very
quickly so i had all these like half
filled out paper journals that i
just i mean i still have them lord knows
what i was writing about
some crush but um but these day these
days
i'm like my computer is my is my
favorite like
probably one of my favorite pizza like
you know product possessions because i'm
just writing all my ideas in there
sometimes if aaron is like holding my
laptop because it possesses all of my
stories on it
and if he's if like it's on the edge of
the table or something i'll be like hold
on
my computer it's everything i have
thank you by the way for saying that
to the person
i feel good okay all right and he i get
a big laugh from him every time he's
like it's all you have
and i'm like i mean i might just have
that conversation
i'm glad to hear that i'm not the only
one too
oh boy but so you did write intro
because you said you this need to
and i know i know part of journal
writing is about that it's like this
need to get
things out whether it's ideas or
feelings or whatever
so i was just wondering yeah you did
that yeah i had the journal and you know
it was a little bit more for like an
emotional
process when i was younger i was you
know as a kid
you're still figuring it out you're
figuring out who you even are who you're
gonna be
and so sometimes i liked committing
certain days maybe even more emotional
days like down in a
in a diary because you're like okay whoa
look at this i was really feeling
something on this day
and you might be able to use that i
understand
i'll actually even write my own self
emails to this day
if i'm having a really hard day or or if
i'm having a really good day i'll send
myself an email i kind of call it like
talking to victoria in the future it's
like i know i'm a huge like email nerd i
guess but
um it's to remind myself of like good
and bad days so it's like today is a
really bad day and here's what's going
on
um you know hey future victoria i hope
things are better and then
i'll read that later and be like i
didn't have anything to worry about that
day
why was i so upset that day and it's
actually been really cathartic to
put that in perspective you know there's
always going to be certain days where
you're kind of feeling
good or bad and on the bad days you can
kind of see like
that might happen don't sweat it don't
don't stress too hard on that day
you know try try your best to just kind
of
move it through you move it move past it
so that's a little something i do to try
and stay like mentally healthy
that's really cool you should do a
screenplay about that like the female
character that's like writing letters to
themselves
yeah yeah kind of like i'm like from the
pad like two characters there that's
interesting yeah i grabbed my phone
hopefully
yeah it was really cool i could see that
being part of you know because i think
of remember um julie and julia
like amy adams character and she was
kind of like i don't know she was really
she wasn't really
writing to herself but she was blogging
and it just kind of almost reminds me of
that a little bit and absolutely and
i think like sometimes you can be really
honest with yourself
especially if you know if you think
you're going to be the only one who's
reading it
you can be pretty honest with what's
making you feel down even if it's like
someone and your life is really giving
you a hard time it's like you can go
ahead and talk about that to yourself
in the email and so i will occasionally
and then that
really really has helped me like i've
been doing that for a few years now
and it's been so helpful and maybe times
were a little bit harder a few years ago
when i was
when the filmmaking career was a little
bit less clear you know i didn't know
how i was going to be making it as a
filmmaker it's like
am i even going to be able to sell this
movie what am i even going to be able to
act in the scene like things were very
murky
and so i was constantly feeling like
what what's the future what is the
future and so that's why i like kind of
writing to my future self and
letting her know like what's been going
on with me back then
i read it now and i'm like oh you had
nothing to worry about you can do it
it's a little bit more cathartic for me
now at present so it's been helpful yeah
where did you come up with that that's
really fascinating letters to victoria i
like that
it's been it's something i probably have
always done to some capacity maybe not
emailing it to myself but i've uh i'm
really
it's a good question but i'll answer it
so i'm an only child
and i grew up in a small town where i
didn't really you know the houses were
far away
far apart like my parents didn't always
like take me to go see my friends i
would spend quite a little bit of time
by myself
and so i sometimes would just
not talk to myself but be very aware of
myself and just kind of kind of
kind of talk to myself and in a way that
was just like treating myself as a
friend like hey how are we feeling you
know
it's just a little it's helpful it makes
me feel less alone
no one can know me better than me and so
it kind of sometimes i'll just envision
myself like
past versions of myself and even
hopefully future versions of myself and
and what i hope for both of those
versions and it always makes me feel
like i've got
you know a lot of friends present when
i'm thinking about myself in that
capacity
thinking about myself a lot you know i'm
an only child too and i think my
grandmother used to send me this
newsletter it was kind of like the
lonely onlys and i thought
but no i'm not like i'm having fun i
know how to entertain myself
yeah i think that being an only child is
sometimes where
a lot of creative people like draw their
creativity
you figure out cool ways to entertain
only you
like and it's very fun it's like the sky
is the limit when you're just like it's
just me
what can we do right it's
i've learned how to you know just keep
myself very occupied so
yeah and like with everything you've
you've built i mean you have this
amazing channel you're inspiring other
creators like
you figured i mean there were this there
was a time where this channel didn't
exist and you just thought it
spoke it like put it into action and now
here it is and
i get to be here on it well thank you
and also too and another person sitting
in my left is also an only child
and so and it was his initial ideas so
yeah
so only children come up only children
interesting
and aaron is an only child we're four
only oh my god
yeah i think there's something to it i
think there's something to being an only
child
i do i do yeah or or maybe some of them
um that have like siblings that are much
older yeah oh yeah kind of used to
entertaining yourself yeah the
non-lonely onlys
the not so lonely yeah
you